[Música]
para muchos esta esquina de mineápolis
en eeuu es terreno sagrado para expresar
su indignación un sinnúmero de personas
llega a diario al lugar donde la
brutalidad policial acabó con la vida de
george floyd el 25 de mayo de 2020
el episodio fue la chispa que
desencadenó el movimiento mundial contra
el racismo más grande del siglo 21
durante 8 minutos y 46 segundos el
entonces policía derecho bin presionó su
rodilla contra el cuello de floyd quien
permanecía en el suelo esposado tras ser
arrestado por sospechas de entregar un
billete falso en una pierna una serie de
protestas tanto pacíficas como violentas
se tomaron estados unidos de costa a
costa y se extendieron hasta el día de
hoy aunque con menos intensidad los
manifestantes dieron fuerza a black
lights matter el movimiento que surgió
en 2013 y que fue creciendo a medida que
aumentaba el número de afroamericanos
muertos en manos de la policía
los disturbios saqueos y enfrentamientos
con la fuerza pública llevaron a las
autoridades a imponer toques de queda ya
desplegar la guardia nacional en varios
estados del país el tema causó una
profunda división en la sociedad
estadounidense las fronteras no
detuvieron el malestar por el caso floyd
y las protestas por el respeto a las
vidas afro llegaron a europa américa
latina áfrica y algunos países de medio
oriente se desató una ola de rechazo a
los símbolos relacionados con el
colonialismo y la esclavitud estatuas de
conquistadores y otros monumentos fueron
derribadas alrededor del mundo a casi un
año del primer aniversario del asesinato
de georg floyd la sed de justicia sigue
intacta y este lunes derecho bin será
juzgado por homicidio en segundo grado
homicidio en tercer grado y homicidio
involuntario de ser declarado culpable
enfrentaría hasta 40 años de prisión
otros ex oficiales que lo acompañaban a
que el 25 de mayo están acusados de
complicidad y se espera que sean
juzgados este verano pero más que una
condena la sociedad quiere que haya un
cambio en nombre de georg floyd y otros
que murieron bajo las mismas
circunstancias